dernière prière du vendredi avant la fin
du ramadan certains ici prie pour que la
colère des palestiniens leur donne la
liberté
je crois que ça fera naître quelque
chose de beau dit la jeune amira
dans le vieux gaza on fonde plus
d'espoir une manifestation des
palestiniens que dans l'ardeur des
efforts diplomatiques
un cessez-le-feu on n'y croit pas
tellement
on n'a jamais rien obtenu deux disent
allez parlant 10 israéliens on ne peut
pas leur faire confiance
la guerre continue elle continue de
détruire de réclamer des vies
nous avons besoin de ces cinq joueurs
dit mohammed à propos d'une trêve
temporaire les israéliens aussi j'espère
qu'ils pourront s'asseoir et négocier un
long cécile feu nous avons besoin de
paix ici
mohamed habib tech à jahia depuis
l'offensive terrestre des forces
israéliennes l'endroit a plutôt des airs
de ville fantôme ceux qui s'y trouvent
profitent surtout d'une accalmie des
combats pour venir chercher quelques
effets personnels
l'accalmie des combats dans sa jahia ee
relative depuis notre arrivée on entend
le bourdonnement constant des drones au
dessus de nos têtes pas très loin dans
les rues avoisinantes le sont très
claires des combats rapprochés des tirs
d'armes légères et d'armes lourdes
la famille lé lot a décidé elle d'y
revenir
quand même
nous allons mourir dans nos maisons mais
nous ne quitterons pacha zhai a dit
nadia la famille dit que ce sont les
enfants qui ont demandé de rentrer chez
eux je me dis que c'est mieux de mourir
à la maison et de vivre dans la dignité
dit la petite news sera dix ans c'est
pour ne pas perdre la dignité que les
scénarios de cessez-le-feu proposé sont
inacceptables sans entre autres la levée
immédiate du blocus israélien de
l'enclavé palestinienne qui se porte
parole du rallye
nous voulons un cessez le feu mais un
cessez le feu sans notre liberté ce
n'est pas possible nous ne l'accepterons
pas
la liberté ou la mort ce n'est peut-être
pas le choix qu'avait fait anas et saad
escaffit impossible de leur poser la
question
les jumeaux de 18 ans sont morts au même
instant dans un bombardement israélien
cinq jours plus tard on vient tout juste
de retrouver leurs corps ils se
marièrent